in the last video I've mentioned how
I've been asked to make predictions for
the year 2016 the last one I focused on
education that's obviously what what I'm
working on now so I I have some opinions
about that but what I want to do in this
video is do maybe slightly more broad
and wild predictions and my one
prediction I'll make is on probably
completely not going to predict the real
reality of 2060 and probably the really
big things to predict I will completely
miss but with that out of the way it is
fun to predict things so let's give a
shot so the first area that I will
predict is what's going to happen in the
field of medicine in particular I think
that the human lifespan is going to
increase dramatically so I'll be
conservative and say that the lifespan
the average human lifespan is going to
be and especially in the developed world
and once again hopefully by 2060 most of
the world is developed the Hugh average
human lifespan is going to be over a
hundred years old and I won't say
whether that's going to be a good or a
bad thing there's arguments either way
about about the proper way to to live
and it end and what happens to global
populations but if the world is for the
most part developed and educated you
actually will probably have a lower
lower rate of reproduction and so you
might actually have some space in the
world for older people but this I think
is there's a very strong chance of this
happening because we are starting to
understand the molecular basis of Aging
it's not a it's not a given thing that
that because of some form of wear and
tear things have to die at after 70
years or 80 years or 90 years and we're
starting to understand the mechanisms
and how to maybe improve the repair
mechanisms or how to augment it in some
way so I definitely think this is going
to happen I well I don't know whether
it's going to be a positive or negative
but it's likely to happen the next thing
and this is kind of closely related this
is still biological is you're going to
have a close integration between the
digital and the biological so digital
digital and biological and once again I
won't make any statement of whether this
is a good or bad thing but it seems like
it's just an extrapolation of the
direction
we're already going in digital and
biological integration so already you're
getting more and more in your handheld
devices imagine when your handheld when
your screen is now no longer in your
palm but it's being projected onto your
retina from some little thing and then
eventually you have a direct connection
with your retina and your brain can
directly access areas of memory through
just direct through some biological
and-and-and digital interface so I
definitely think this going to happen
this is a big deal because this is
starting to and I think it's already
happening with what some lot of what you
see around technology it's really going
to it's really going to reshape what the
individual human experience is going to
be we already see people kind of living
in virtual realities and playing these
these these immersive games and spending
all of their time on social networking
platforms what happens when they're
literally plugged in all the time when
almost their cell phone is in the brain
I don't know I'm not going to comment
whether it's a good or bad thing but it
does look like a trend that's going to
keep on going through the next 50 years
now if we take that even further we're
talking about a digital and biological
integration but if you go at the extreme
and actually it's probably both of these
top two things combined in some way is
that we are learning and once again not
making a comment whether it's good or
bad it's just an extrapolation of what
we're already seeing we are seeing more
and more ability to understand our
genome to molecularly target things to
manipulate actual biology and so what
you have is that you can actually have
let me write this manipulation
manipulation of biology and why this is
on some level creepy it could be creepy
or it could be exciting depending on how
it all plays out but it could do things
like augment intelligence augment human
intelligence which would if you think
about all the progress of society and
all the things that already accelerating
imagine what except house aasaiya T will
change if intelligence itself is
augmented you know and as someone with a
limited intelligence I can't even
imagine what will happen as soon as you
do this and obviously the more you
augment intelligence the more that you
can you more that you can learn how to
augmented telogen San increase lifespan
and do digital button biological
integration even more so these things I
see as some form of a trend we'll see
how it all plays out and hopefully it
plays it out in the in the in the in the
kind of the the feel-good Care Bear
version versus the kind of you know some
type of crazy society and we all turn
into the Borg in some way now the other
trend and I'm just these are the things
that just popped into my brain today
when I pressed record but the other
trend that I think is interesting is
some of the things that we've taken for
granted in terms of how nations
integrate interact with each other and
nation states in particular interact
with each other and just as a kind of an
overview so there's a notion called a
nation a nation state and in everyday
language the word nation and the word
state almost means the same thing but
they kind of mean different things if
you want to be a little bit more formal
about and that's why people use the word
nation state they don't that's like you
know to a lot of people it doesn't say
mean saying like state state the
difference between a nation in the state
is these are a group of people that feel
some type of common identity it could be
a language it could be a culture it
could be a value system so this is some
kind of common identity and it often is
somehow associated with geography but it
does not have to be associated geography
it could even be a religion or it could
be whatever else that's what a nation is
a state a state is a formal governance
structure that makes the laws and has
the institutions to make to make society
function now a nation-state is what most
of us live in today because it both has
an identity and some type of formal
institutions so a very pure nation state
would be someplace like Japan where
there's there's relatively uniform in
terms of ethnicity and religion and in
terms of culture and you have that same
group of people or our governor are
governing themselves in a place like the
United States ethnicity religion that's
diverse but what gives identity is a
notion of shared values and a notion of
maybe a common history or whatever else
for a certain kind of worldview and
obviously there's a formal state
structure now what I think is going to
be
and I actually have no idea how all of
this is going to play out but when you
see things like some of the revolutions
in the Middle East to do two things like
people being able to communicate
irrespective of the traditional media I
think there's going to be some
interesting questions on what happens to
the nation-state especially a nation
states that that that are able to secure
their power by by kind of having a
bottleneck on access to information and
all of that is I think going to change
in a very dramatic way as you have more
and more integration between people
cross-border communications when people
realize that the people on the other
side of the border really aren't that
different than themselves and another
interesting thing even the notion of
democracy and once again I don't know
how it's going to play out but all
notions of representational democracy
that we have today are somewhat based on
geography they're somewhat based on
geography and that's because when the
the major representational democracies
came about that was the best way to
represent each other hey let me pick
some representatives from our County or
from our region and they'll go elect
other representatives and they'll go to
the national government but now that we
have this instantaneous communication
with people you might be able to have
different types of a representational
democracy or maybe you could even have
more direct democracies who knows
because of because of things like
communication and technology and
whatever else and then the other way
that I think nation-states are the way
they fundamentally interaction going to
change is actually in things like
warfare and once again already seeing
this trend in particular I think
developed countries are not going to
have humans on the front line no humans
no humans on the front line and
depending on your point of view this
could be a very good thing or it could
be a kind of a scary thing because if
you have no humans on the front line and
you're already seeing things like this
with these Predator drones predator
Predator drones and you see these kind
of these these robot bomb these robot
bomb detectors and on things like that
and it doesn't even have to be these big
things there's already a DARPA funded
project to work on
miniature insects that could be used as
some form of reconnaissance or you could
imagine eventually they could have these
little things on them that could knock
someone out or who knows what they do
the exciting things
is that all of a sudden a huge shot and
so hopefully military casualties would
go down the scary thing here is if you
if you don't have humans on the
frontline nations might be willing to
enter into war especially developed
nations that they might not take it as
seriously and so it might be something
that they do a little bit more you know
when they're in the mood and it would
actually create a huge disparity between
developed and developing nations when
this happens and you already see that to
a certain degree a developed nation they
don't have to put as many humans in
harm's way and it's purely driven by
their their wealth to to have capital
that can go you know these robots and
these drones and their technological
innovate innovation while in the
developing countries they actually would
have to use human beings so their costs
would be much much much much higher so
it's an interesting question and once
again it's you know who knows how this
plays out whether it's a good or bad
thing in the long term I think a similar
thing with this is I think we're going
to see more and more non-lethal weapons
non-lethal non-lethal weapons which once
again it's very similar to this it
sounds like it's a good thing you know
if there's a gun that instead of having
to kill someone it incapacitate them in
some way or it stuns them in some way
you know kind of the classic Star Trek
put your phasers on stun things the the
I guess the scarier version of
non-lethal weapons is the threshold for
using it becomes much lower so if a
government is you know wants to subject
its citizens or subject another group of
citizens it can literally just stun them
or it can make them pass out or it could
control them in some way and so this
could be this could be a little bit
scarier so who knows how all of this
plays out so those are my those are my
predictions or things to think about
over the next 50 years these are just
the things that happen to jump into my
brain today probably based on some of
the science fiction books I've been
reading or whatever else but take them
with a huge grain of salt I don't know
if these things are really going to
happen or not and I don't know if
they're even a good thing or not but
they seem to be a bit of an
extrapolation of what we're already
seeing